supreme court hypocrisy on full display
in the mainstream media liberals going
into overdrive trying to defend biden's
radical nominee and absolutely losing
their minds any time somebody has the
nerve to question her record as a judge
josh hawley you know fist in the air
josh and slave holder descendant tom
cotton reprised they're cueing on
baiting smears against judge katanji
brown jackson they were treating her
like a black shopper being that they
were following through the store a day
of grandstanding and speech making and
hissy fitting in the senate today no
republican has been more hot and
bothered than lindsey graham of south
carolina this is about midterm elections
appealing to culture wars appealing to a
segment of the gop that uh
is into conspiracy theories in
particular senator blackburn's line of
questioning did you see racism in any of
that
all right jessica did you see any racism
at the hearing
and can you give me an example
i saw a lot of stuff that i didn't like
i did not feel like there were racial
undertones to it the argument that has
been
made about that is that talking down to
someone and you can interpret some of
these questions which feel
like the gotcha questions like could you
please define a woman that that's
talking down to someone and then would
they be doing that to someone who was a
white nominee i think is the line of
argumentation that it would do it but i
i did not see that i saw some stuff i
didn't like and i went back though
to look at what went on during amy coney
barrett's hearings just to make sure
this really was just a completely
one-sided thing with the adulation
that's coming for democrats and
obviously we saw cory booker go off for
a few minutes but you know filled with
joy at the moment and i i myself am
excited about it but we did see senators
tillis grassley graham you know going on
and on amy coney barrett is a mother she
has seven children two adopted uh five
biological lindsey graham even actually
upped it to nine children by accident
he's like well i'll have two more and
then john cornyn he was the one who had
her hold up her blank page of notes and
he said isn't it so imp that was what if
it's a nice moment why is that a nice
moment when you think you thought it was
cool
that she doesn't have to take notes and
that should make you more qualified to
be on the supreme court so when you
that's the moment
straight fawning she knows what a woman
is everyone does this janine right the
democrats they're nasty when the
republican nominee comes up vice versa
this is the way the game's played the
media acts like this is the first
hearing we've ever had well look i mean
i it doesn't take much to say that the
the the way this judge is being
questioned is so much more polite than
what they did to amy coney barrett than
what they did to brett kavanaugh i mean
it was just a circus let's admit it i
mean everybody said they didn't want it
to be like that and the republicans i
think have been kind enough to make sure
that it isn't but you know what the
whole point of the questioning is to get
an idea of who this judge is the judge
that refuses to identify her judicial
philosophy when other judges do so we go
through the truth-finding process we've
done it for centuries and the
truth-finding process is when you put
someone under oath and you ask them
questions to try to get at the truth and
that's what we're doing here so we have
this this this candidate for the highest
court in the land where we've got to ask
her questions she repeatedly tells us
how much she loves america she loves
america everybody's like yay this is
wonderful she loves america but then she
routinely routinely refers to government
officials as war criminals and it's not
just in the caption it's not just in the
caption in a lawsuit okay number one
number two she repeatedly tells us that
her brother's in law enforcement she
knows law enforcement we're like yeah
that's great but then through
cross-examination
we find out that with child pornography
she is down uh sentencing below the
sentencing guidelines and let me tell
you what child pornography is it's a
visual depiction of a minor engaging in
sexually explicit conduct i don't care
what her excuses now i got a third one
she can't define what a woman is she
could have said i'm a woman or a woman
someone who gives birth or anything but
she doesn't want to be unmasked we are
master in the first two now
let me finish let me finish number four
crt oh i think it's something they teach
in law school we all know if you
followed any of the news in virginia
what's going on in this country and it's
not about law school and she's on the
board of a school where they're teaching
critical race theory now she has been
unmasked differently and now we've found
out her philosophy does that mean she
won't be a justice she will be because
they got the numbers but let's not kid
each other if she'd been honest in the
beginning we wouldn't have to go through
the truth-finding process that's all i
have to say
so i'll just quickly say something i'm
going to channel greg gutfeld for a
moment and just talk about the media for
a second because good job go back to
kavanaugh for a second and do you
remember when the media were the biggest
drivers of weak rumors that then the
media put forward and then they had to
walk them back um and all of a sudden
now the shoes on the other foot with uh
jackson and
there's also no intellectual curiosity
about anything that's going on with some
of these perpetrators that she sentenced
when kavanaugh was up we had profiles of
everyone he had gone to school with
since preschool yeah and the washington
post today was like oh well the rebel
republicans have been so much worse i
mean come on where are
where are the
profiles of these people especially the
ones who reoffended don't you think
you'd maybe be curious enough as a
journalist that might be something that
you might want to follow up on but they
didn't do it no they didn't did they
greg they didn't they didn't excellent
point you know i saw racism it was in
that media montage if you can't ask
tough questions of a person of color
then basically that's a form of bigotry
right how do you know you you it's such
a and i know this sounds like a racial
term you don't if every time you ask a
person of color causes you to be a white
knight
that means you don't believe that person
of color can answer the question that's
what i see uh but again this is i i
don't get tyrus angry this is a lot like
professional wrestling uh we already
know the outcome right and but people
the the
politicians are still playing their
roles and you're right they reverse
every time we know what's happening i
think the best win for republicans is to
let the democrats win because they are
as the judge says hope that your
behavior
your polite behavior might pay a
dividend later probably won't but maybe
it will but at this point all you are is
you you're feeding that media every time
you try to grandstand for a viral moment
uh that that's what you know cory booker
loves to do right did he cry yesterday i
think he'd cry yeah i think so but but
there is this weird amnesia and i can't
tell if it's deliberate or it's
oblivious that in order for all of that
montage to adopt that stance they have
to forget everything that has happened
in the last 30 to 40 years you know yes
i do know and i think it's smart of you
i do i think it's smart of you not to
try to get tyrus angry yeah that's true
because he would crush it he would he
would great but i would enjoy it you
sicko
up next
he's
perfect
he's perfect for now
nancy pelosi has a new midterm message
but
who's gonna buy that